hey guys i'm abby sharp and welcome to
Abby's kitchen today we're gonna be
reviewing one of dr. Mona vans YouTube
videos on how to get rid of bloating
since this has been a really heavily
requested video it's time to address
this also based on some feedback and
some soul-searching I'm also going to
start to try to shift how I do my
youtuber reviews focusing more on
overall themes rather than kind of
nitpicking one meal at a time I also
think that this is really just gonna
help you make more informed decisions
about which youtubers and influencers
are really great to follow and which
ones mmm you might want to take a pass
on okay so let's get into it right here
so dr. Mona is a pharmacist influencer
TV guest and youtuber but she does tend
to speak a lot about nutrition and
health on her channel her philosophy is
that you know medication is of course
part of the equation for good health but
the rest is living a healthy lifestyle
which I actually think we can ultimately
agree on so we're gonna watch this video
and I'll let you know my honest opinions
on some of the claims so I've got a bag
of spinach here now the interesting
thing is that raw greens are so good for
us there's something that like anyone
would encourage you to eat more of but
they can really cause a lot of bloating
and sometimes the foods with the highest
fiber or like the raw healthy like
veggies can end up causing bloating so
I'm gonna help you guys find a way to
slow get these in okay so dr. Mona is
talking about how raw greens can often
cause bloating and we might avoid them
because of that and it is true that
eating an excessive amount of fiber and
fiber rich raw veggies can cause
bloating and even some other unpleasant
digestive issues depending on the
individual I agree with dr. Mona that
you don't want to avoid these foods
because of this reason so she gives a
really great tip that steaming them is a
really great way to get all those
nutrients without the bloat so anytime
we cook a food
we break it down slightly doing some of
the work before I digest of system
actually gets to it and steaming is a
really great cooking method
because it retains a lot of the
nutrients without them getting
completely lost in the cooking water so
Bravo literally the key here is to just
steam them yes like raw technically has
more nutrients but if you just lightly
steal your greens you're still gonna get
so much benefit
okay so just raw across the board always
have more nutrients than cooked while
it's true that in some cases cooking a
food may remove some of its nutrients
there are also other cases where you
know cooking a food can actually
increase the nutrient content for
example
cooking certain foods like carrots and
tomatoes can increase its antioxidant
content in fact one study found that the
absorption of beta-carotene was six
point five times greater in stir-fried
carrots compared to raw carrots so
that's why it's a good idea to sometimes
you know switch up your preparation so
your body has a variety of nutrients and
you have a variety of flavors and
textures to enjoy I mean pleasure is
also a really important part of healthy
eating but fruit can make you extremely
bloated so one amazing alternative here
one day into a smoothie this is actually
also better for digestion because
basically when you're blending your pre
digesting your food so anything that's a
more liquid is gonna get digested and
absorbed better into your body then when
it's solid so you're getting more
nutrients you actually can get more bang
for your buck because you can get more
in like mango or whatever it was but
don't underestimate using water even the
green smoothie that I have in my channel
that I can link below this video it's
blended with water there's a lot to
unpack here well I am also a total
smoothie fan there are a few things that
dr. Mona mentions in her kind of owed to
smoothies here that I don't completely
agree with so yes
blending fruits will do some of the
digestion for you but I don't agree that
foods in liquid form are any more
nutritious or absorbed better than solid
foods necessarily our body's job is to
break down everything to eat using a
variety of digestive enzymes and then
that food gets absorbed and utilized
efficiently for normal healthy eaters
there's also not a lot of
evidence to suggest that liquefying
foods measurably improves nutrition
status or reduces bloating anecdotally
however I do sometimes hear that it can
help with bloating but if this sounds
like you it might be because a you're
dealing with some IBS symptoms and
therefore excessive amounts of fiber
could be irritating so pre digesting
that fiber in a blender may
theoretically help or be you're healthy
but you're not chewing your food enough
this is a surprisingly common problem I
mean we eat really fast intersociety so
if you're bloated after a salad this is
often why I mean I'm a mom I to eat
really really fast interestingly
smoothies come with a lot of hidden
bloating risks as well if you're
drinking your smoothie through a straw
or chugging it back in big gulps it's
very common to swallow air and in fact
ninety percent of gas in your gut is
just swallowed air and then we basically
just get rid of that air by burping or
farting it out another thing that is not
considered here is that chewing your
food gives your body more time to
secrete gastric digestive enzymes which
should also aid in better digestion so
as long as you're chewing your foods
your whole foods really well before
swallowing and you don't have any
serious pre-existing digestive issues
like IBS I don't think that the benefits
of a smoothie would outweigh the
potential downsides eating foods in
solid form can also be more physically
and emotionally satiating one said he
found that liquids don't give he's the
same satiation factor as solids
even for the same amount of calories
likely because the act of chewing itself
clearly tells the brain that you're
eating calories I also find that people
tend to consume more calories in liquid
form because it's ultimately way easier
to chug calories than to chew and
swallow them so for example it's not
that hard to drink a smoothie containing
two bananas and two apples but it might
take a long time to eat two whole
bananas and two whole apples I mean
unless you're freely so liquefying a lot
of your foods may actually confuse your
hunger and fullness cues leading you to
eat more calories than what your body
usually needs while dr. Mona recommends
a smoothie because she says that you
know you can better absorb the nutrients
we also don't want food to pass right
through us either smoothies are
technically predigested which means will
absorb it faster that being said when we
miss out on the extra step of digestion
that our body is trained to do you'll
likely end up with an empty tank pretty
quickly foods that pass right through us
like simple sugars in a smoothie can
cause a spike in our blood sugar and
leave us susceptible to overeating
shortly after whereas when we eat whole
foods that extra step of digestion may
help you feel fuller longer finally I
want to flag dr. Moniz comment about
getting more nutrients from a smoothie
by blending it with water this is where
dr. Mona is kind of tearing into the
woolly food combining territory dr.
Moniz theory here is that if you
eliminate nutrient dense liquids like
milk and instead blend your fruit with
water the fruits will be better and more
effectively absorbed and you'll get more
nutrients out of it
this is based on the food combining
theory principle that if you give your
body too many nutrient dense foods it
will slow down digestion and the
absorption and nutrients will be also
slowed so if you eliminate the number of
nutrient dense foods and you swap in
water for your smoothie dr. Mona
believes that you can reap more of the
nutrients from the fruit obviously
there's no scientific proof to confirm
any of this I think we've already
squashed this myth pretty well right
here first of all whether you eat the
whole fruit you blend it up or you add
water most people are going to reap the
same approximate amount of nutrients
well adding water is a great trick to
stay hydrated and even improve the
palate ability of certain fruits or
vegetables that you might have
difficulty eating as a whole food
there's no evidence that it can reduce
bloating or that you can get more
nutrients out of it in fact the best way
to maximize your smoothie situation and
get
more nutrients out of it is to add more
nutrients so instead of nutrient free
water maybe add some healthy fats from
avocado or nut butter or protein from
Greek yogurt or tofu or soy milk that is
certain to increase the nutrient value
of your drink not adding water the last
tip I have is what you're combining so
the simpler you can make your meals the
better sometimes when you mix and
million things together it's just your
body's working to digest too many things
so I really recommend trying to simplify
your meals even sticking to maximum like
three or four foods per meal
I don't want to spend too much time on
food combining because I have a whole
video on it here that you can check out
if you haven't already seen that I also
wrote a blog post on food combining so
I'm gonna leave the link below in the
description so definitely check that out
but here dr. Mona mentions that when you
have too many foods in a meal you're
giving your body too much work to digest
it all and ultimately it kind of like
this is this whole food combining theory
is that at least like a traffic jam on a
conveyor belt
oh god this both this is what your body
is for let your body do its job it knows
what it's doing unless there's an
underlying digestive issue a healthy
digestive system doesn't get into a
traffic jam for eating fat with fruit or
whatever I mean like in any healthy
digestive system our body sends out the
right cocktail of enzymes to get the job
done every single time you don't need to
try to manipulate every meal to somehow
isolate certain macronutrients not only
is that totally unnecessary but it's
also virtually impossible because you
know even dr. mona mentions at one point
that one single food can contain a
variety of vitamins and minerals and
macronutrients so it's also you know got
a variety of different carbs and
proteins and fats please
let's put that food combining myth to
bed I also feel that you know her
description of you know not including
both carbohydrates like quinoa and wall
in the same bowl is a real missed
opportunity to build a really balanced
meal including a source of fiber protein
and healthy fats in each meal is your
surefire way to improve satiety and keep
those blood sugar stable all day long I
would way rather see a person have you
know a little bit of carbs from the
quinoa and a little bit of fat from the
walnuts versus no carbs and lots of fat
from lots of walnuts and then at the
next meal have no fat and lots of carbs
I mean you're just asking for energy
fluctuations throughout the day
next I'm really not deprivation being
like you can't these foods ever like
it's you know especially when they're so
good for you so I just want to encourage
everyone not to have fear eating or like
food fear where they don't want to eat
certain things so just try these little
tips of extra water you know cooking
them a little bit longer blending them
and I think will really help you and
also it will help you absorb more the
food really the food that you eat you're
not getting any benefit from unless your
body's absorbing it so you're not
digesting it properly might as well not
so I like dr. Moniz point here about not
fearing food or fear eating I can
totally get behind that even though I
feel like it's kind of at odds with a
lot of other messages on her channel but
still I'm glad she at least put that out
there as a way to suggest that yeah like
in general you know we still want you to
eat all these good healthy foods also
dr. Mona is right and saying that if
you're not digesting something properly
you know you may not be absorbing the
nutrients from that food however I would
disagree with dr. Moniz recommendation
of only including a few foods in one
meal to improve absorption in some cases
the more nutrient-dense foods combined
the better absorption of nutrients for
example combining vitamin C rich foods
with plant-based iron rich foods can
increase the absorption of heme iron
which is especially important for vegans
or people following a plant-based
lifestyle another example is that in one
study blood lycopene levels were
increased by 80% when people consumed
their tomatoes saute and in olive oil
other than without it in this situation
the addition of fat improved the
absorption and increased the tomatoes
antioxidant content or consider how
combining carbohydrates and protein
after a workout for example can help
speed up muscle recovery and replenish
glycogen stores that were depleted
during your workout there are lots and
lots and lots of benefits to food
combining that are actually grounded in
evidence and avoiding a digestive
traffic jam is not one of them another
thing to consider is if you're not able
to absorb the nutrients from a food
there is a possibility that something
more serious might be going on there are
a number of conditions that can impact
the absorption of nutrients things like
short bowel syndrome Crohn's disease
chronic pancreatitis lactase deficiency
celiac disease etc these are serious
conditions that need medical supervision
and simply adopting dr. Moniz tips like
blending fruits or cooking grains with
more water will not improve absorption
or improve your condition
beyond this video specifically on
bloating I took some time to review dr.
Moniz Channel specifically her health
and wellness playlist and I was a little
surprised to see it littered with a diet
culture slang maybe I wasn't surprised
at all so one of them is called how to
naturally detox every day oh here we go
again so in this video dr. Mona provides
some tips on how to incorporate a gentle
detox which sounds like an oxymoron to
me but throughout the video she talks a
lot about cleansing and clean food and
spend some time discussing some
chlorophyll detox supplement and she
shares a variety of claims that honestly
hold very little bearing in the research
community at one point she mentions that
chlorophyll ate in heavy metal detoxes
which 100% has not been proven she also
briefly discusses intermittent fasting
while also making general claims like
after 16 hours of fasting your body goes
into repair mode and eats away cancerous
cells what the actual I'm sorry but
these claims are horrendous
false and dangerous I am shocked that a
fellow health care provider will be
making these sensationalized statements
without any validated evidence to back
it up in another video titled what to
eat a day for weight loss dr. Mona talks
about starting her day with lemon water
apple cider vinegar and cayenne pepper
hello dr. Mona 2007 is calling and it
wants its Master Cleanse back
she also touts the benefits of for
signetics mushrooms for weight loss and
physical and mental ailments which we
already of course covered here is bunk
and it tastes like legitimate so please
save your money and just drink water
instead now a lot of you have asked me
to review dr. Moniz what I in a day and
while I felt like it was way more
valuable to spend my time focusing on
some of the claims around digestion and
bloating and food combining I want to
finish with a few thoughts on her
recipes and things that I've seen now
aside from some of her juices her meals
seem generally balanced and actually
really delicious
a lot of her salads are pretty nutrient
packed with a nice balance of protein
starch and healthy fats which is great
and you know personally as a viewer and
a fellow health care professional I
would way rather see her focus on making
yummy salads and less on giving
nutrition advice which ultimately is out
of her scope and just plain wrong so in
conclusion well it's really nice to see
other health care professionals dominate
the YouTube space I'm slightly worried
by some of her nutrition claims
considering that she's not a nutrition
expert and more problematically
the little evidence to support the use
of some of these natural remedies also
I'm kind of shocked by YouTube's
obsession with bloating as it's pretty
much become the more socially acceptable
version of I feel so fat I also saw that
she actually just posted a new video on
bloating where she mentions that jerking
fennel and ginger tea may help reduce
bloating and to this I would say
possibly yes ginger has been shown to
help increase stomach emptying by as
much as 50% and fennel tea can help
relax digestive muscles which can help
improve bowel movements she also
discusses gassy foods like the sulfurous
vegetables and carbonated drinks both of
which I would also agree may cause
bloating
so that video is a little bit more my
speed
anyway I'm gonna be chatting way more
about that in an upcoming video about
bloating on a vegan diet so definitely
stay tuned for that until then if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below with
some of your thoughts and your questions
on bloating and any one that you want me
to review subscribe to the channel and I
will see you next time on Abby's kitchen
bye
[Music]